[Music]
okay so
um the last speaker I hope I'm not the
you know it's a tough act to follow all
the great speakers but uh being the last
speaker of the day it's also you know
the energy level has fallen already
perhaps I don't know uh it depends you
know like I hope to keep the energy
levels up
um I'm here to talk about unplexing your
life you know so what the heck is unplex
you know you might ask unplex is the
direct opposite of complex
okay so maybe the last time you checked
the opposite of complex was simple
but they changed it
it's unplexed going forward okay
um let me kick this off by asking some
intriguing questions okay
um have you ever had a suspicion that
your life events have some pattern to it
you know there are some some kind of
perceptible
perhaps weird pattern that you can
perhaps observe
maybe you know if it is something that
is not favorable to you you might have
probably blamed it upon your own
personality maybe that's what is
attracting
these outcomes
maybe you know you thought there is
something even more Sinister at play you
know could be fate
um so okay so how about this one you
know have you ever woken up one day and
felt all anxious worried but you didn't
know really why why is that happening
um how about you know have you ever been
stuck in a mental rut
and wondering is there a way out you
know how about you know being stuck in
the same kind of emotions and feelings
and thought patterns and trying hard to
get out of it
but not finding a way what if you know
we could give a you know you could do it
at the flick of a switch you know you're
able to you know have a different
thought you know a different mindset and
different perspective at will On Demand
is that even possible
how about mindsets you know have you
guys
thought about mindset this is a big
Topic in a lot you know a lot of
organizations you know who are going
through cultural transformation there's
a lot of talk about mindsets mental
models
you know is it even possible for you to
visualize a mental model or a mindset
you know would that produce some
outcomes
would is it possible for you to
deconstruct your mindset and see what it
is made of you know see how things can
connect you know how how your internal
makeup is
would that give you some insights about
yourself
how about an exercise with your team
do you think that would you know change
the Dynamics in your team
who knows okay I'll leave you with these
thoughts uh you know ponder about it
while I flash my beautiful profile okay
once again for people who don't know me
I'm Joe Anthony I've founded a small
company called unplex me again
um it's only been a few months you know
the the offering of onplex me is around
inner Innovation I'll explain what that
is
uh but prior to that I've been an
executive coach at large organizations
the last one was a big Financial
organization in Australia and then prior
to that telecom the the in a nutshell
you know I have coached a lot of uh
people and I've kind of had the
opportunity and the privilege to work
with some great leaders and I understand
human nature to some extent
the key Insight that I've got from all
this learning experience all this
coaching experience is that
humans are wired for growth we all want
to grow okay but we have different
perspectives about growth but broadly
they can be summarized into two kinds of
growth okay the first is external
oriented growth the second is internal
oriented growth
when these two kinds of growth are not
in balance things go A bit off killed
yeah
so what do I mean by external growth you
know when you pursue you know
um higher positions you know we want to
expand your business
positions property and all those kind of
things nothing it's not I'm not saying
that I'm not disparaging it but I'm just
saying that you know it needs to be
balanced with inner growth you know and
at the same time if you just pursue
inner growth and you don't take care of
your externals you know that's also not
good so you need to balance it so what
do I mean by Inner growth you know it's
it you know the things that you the art
sticks of inner growth is something like
um you know your inner Constitution
right how you process your everyday life
um what kind of narratives do you build
up you know what kind of narratives do
you hold about yourself the world and
the people around you you know this is
what I mean by your inner life right
what kind of beliefs that you hold what
are what are your values what is your
sense of purpose and meaning in life
these are some of the art sticks which
kind of tells you if you are able to
clearly articulate this you know then we
we can say that you're in a good space
you know within yourself
how about you know the mindset can you
design your mindset have you considered
that as a possibility is it even
possible for you to you know or is it
something that happens by accident and
by default you know these are kinds of
things that we explore under the broad
Banner of inner Innovation okay so this
is called as the inner growth and inner
growth requires inner work and inner
work is
hugely Amplified
uh by Inner Innovation and unplex me is
all about inspiring inner innovation
okay so let me just
pause
quickly get a sense of the questions
that I was I started the session with
right the few questions that we had
before
um
you know
can I get a sense in the room show of
hands if you guys have ever had
such thoughts you know have you come
across
that feeling
of
anxiety without knowing why
show of hands please thank you thank you
that's very increasing okay that's great
so maybe around fifty percent that's
great so
in my coaching life you know I've been
taking a lot of notes I've been
journaling I've been trying to
understand uh you know more about these
kind of topics and I've kind of
accumulated a lot of material so I'm at
a stage where I think I should be able
to convert that into a book
ok so the next plug is basically
the book that's coming up
um you know it's the same title as the
stop unplex your life incidentally
um so yeah this is while this is coming
up and there's going to be an app that's
going to be published it's going to
teach you more about inner Innovation
and Personal Mastery and the app is is
something that you can use to
immediately practice what you learn from
the book the book is about a few months
away but in the meanwhile if you want to
stay on top of you know these topics you
know please plug into systemic which is
a group within the Stanford lead
workplace
so systemic you know I started this
about a year ago and you know we have a
lot of great things going on so if you
want to stay updated yes please join
systemic
um I only have 30 seconds is it okay to
go because I'm the last speaker am I
allowed
okay
all right so we've kind of introduced a
lot of jargons it would be so unfair if
I leave you without explaining what
these jargons are what is systems
thinking systems thinking is about
looking at reality looking at the world
through a very you know to get a better
and a deeper and a fuller perspective of
what's going on around you okay and
iceberg is a great metaphor you know
because typically when you look at the
iceberg you're only looking at the 10
percent of the iceberg that sticks
outside the water right and in real life
uh you know the the uh the events that
we that we come across you know I'm just
remembering svb you know what happened
last week you know we only realized that
when you know it it's kind of readily
apparent to us but there's lot happening
under the surface in terms of patterns
structures and mental models that we
ignore you know underneath all these
events are systemic patterns that exist
and these patterns are created by
structures that have been you know that
have been put in place somehow and these
structures themselves are a product of
mindsets and Men models and paradigms
and such so this way of thinking and
looking at the world is what we
generally call assistance thing at a
very high level okay
um
in order for us to study these systems
you know we need to be able to you know
we are visual and tactile beings you
know so we like to visualize things we
like to move things around you know play
with it and that's how we learn okay and
you know systems thinking is no
different so you need something like you
know which enables you to do these
things and we have techniques for that
which is called a systems mapping
but drawing pretty pictures is not
enough you know you need to be able to
you know apply that in real life and
learn from you know what you know from
the application of it
so systemic Innovation is a technique by
which you actually create mental models
you apply it against the real world you
get feedback and you keep cycling
through it's a learning process you know
this learning process is what we refer
to as systemic Innovation okay and when
you apply the systemic Innovation to
your own inner headspace okay to your
own uh inner work than we call that as
inner Innovation so these are the high
level Concepts that I want to leave you
guys with
um call to action join systemic group
you know if these topics are of interest
to you there is an unplexed me LinkedIn
page as well feel free to follow that
and you know connect with me on LinkedIn
as well okay so one more thing I'm
looking for great coaches you know who
can actually pick up these topics and
kind of you know
get involved in inner Innovation you
know learn in an innovation and be able
to promote it in your organization or in
your space so if you are interested
please get in touch with me if your
organizations are interested in trialing
this in pioneering this you know please
do get in touch with me
um thank you you guys are really awesome
thank you cheers
[Applause]
[Music]